[Music]
all right hey okay where'd you grow up
were you from originally I grew up in
Inglewood California and tell me about
your childhood you had both your parents
growing up no my father was arrested due
to murder when I was like 2 years old
and my mom got caught up in a street
life so when I was around five who
raised you
my grandmother grandmother mm-hmm how
was your childhood after it was pretty
difficult because I seen all the kids
going to school with parents and I
didn't have either all I had was my
grandmother and later on down the line I
ended up losing her
so everything that seemed like
everything to me I got taken away yeah
what age 12 so from 12 on where'd you go
I had to grow up pretty fast I went with
my other grandmother which there was
always the question as if I belong to
this family or not and it was kind of
hurtful because I felt like the button
the black sheep of the family so I got
pushed away from them too and I ended up
doing a lot of crazy things in life I
started prostituting selling drugs I had
kids at a very young age wait wait you
start working the street I actually
started working on sig in 96 at what age
at 18 yes 18 big and 95th was the first
street I ever got down on this is one of
the most terrifying nights of my life I
was told all these things to do and what
not to do and I was so scared I don't
know what to do if somebody might kidnap
me kill me but I ran with it because it
was the only way that I could find a
source of income did you ever attend yes
I did and how did he treat you actually
every guy that I've dealt with in that
line of work were more so in love with
me
versus trying to pimp me so it was I did
it my choice but not because he forced
me to
and any men that I dealt went in that
field had their own hustle meaning they
were drug dealers or had jobs to where
it was both 50/50 we both bringing
something to the table but I have had my
fair share of some that work kind of
crazy that we're abusive that took all
my money that would leave me out all
night and they went and just spent money
on cars chains and other women while I
worked hard for it it was pretty painful
but eventually you grow after it you
learn what to do and what not to do so
back to that first night that you were
working the street mm-hmm how do you
remember that night yes I do I remember
it as if it just happened yesterday the
guy we ended up meeting each other that
night and I thought he wanted to be my
boyfriend right so I went I chilled what
about his family's house and he was like
have you ever sold that before and I was
like what do you mean by that he was
like you know like you could get paid
for it but let me test the product first
to see how much it worth and I'm
thinking he's joking right so we messing
around and then he's like alright
seriously we shouldn't go to figure
eight now and I was like okay well call
me crazy
I thought it was better you know I'm out
here messing around with men for free
why not get a dollar for it so he told
me okay you're not supposed to date
black people you're not supposed to get
in cars with these license plates you're
not supposed to do is not pushed back
gave me the whole rundown and I like
[ __ ]
whoa first mistake I made was jumping in
the car with a black man and I found out
the reason was because nine times I have
seen their pimps right so I jumped in
the car
every dollar that I made it's just rules
to this game so every dollar that I made
he took my money
he took my cell phone he called the dude
that I was messing with let him know
yeah she was out of pocket I'm taking
everything and she got to pay me I was
like damn this is how this work okay
I have no saying none of it I just went
with it eventually the more I
in the game the more I got more of the
game and I was able to start doing
things on my own and it made my game a
lot tighter and it made me a lot wiser
listening to other females stories and
the things that they've been through it
kind of made me stronger have you been
arrested for it yes
Linwood knows me personally I'm sorry I
said Linwood Oh Kenny Gil knows me
personally which is sad and unfortunate
but yes so how did you end up down here
on Skid Row
oh I ended up down here on Skid Row
because I had hit my rock bottom I was
with the love of my life who had just
been arrested and not too long before
that happened I had had all three of my
children taken away from me so I had
already felt like I was a little empty
so to have the person that helped me get
through this stuff get taken away from
me it kind of toward me down which led
me to do drugs I was popping ecstasy
pills I was doing coke I was doing
crystal the only thing I'm never tried
in this world is heroin and crack and
acid but I was doing everything and I
ended up losing places I had to stay and
I ended up coming down here which I met
my mom which was no help cuz every time
like I mean she'll throw a dollar or two
every now and again but to actually say
that she genuinely cares they wanna talk
to me and figure out the things that I'm
going through now I never felt like she
wanted to do that but I came down here
and I started to get to know people like
genuinely caring about who these people
are in what do they have the offer
because there's a lesson and everybody
that would meet whether you take the
lesson or leave it it's up to you so I
met this guy down here and I met him
through my mother he was like a really
good friend we connected on levels that
I can't even explain
like conversation why's he never came at
me disrespectfully like I really felt
like it was something special about him
so I gave him the time of day like just
to be friends and one day we decided to
take that friendship a little further
than what it was and I feel like that
was the worst mistake that I could have
made downtown I got pregnant by this guy
I stopped talking to the love of my life
for this guy
like it felt like I could have a piece
of happiness and if I could have that I
was willing to let go anything that
would stop it from unfolding so I
stopped talking to a lot of men I
stopped talking to the person who I felt
God made for me just to see where things
would go with this person I ended up
finding out a couple of weeks ago that I
was pregnant I told the guy he said
whatever you decide to do I got you back
you don't matter so I decided to keep my
child because it's just not something
that I wanted to get rid of I've been
through that before and there's
something very painful that no woman I
feel should ever have to go through so
we both decided okay this is what we're
gonna do so he asked me well what do we
need to do to make sure that we don't
bring our child into this world in a
tent so we hustled and the whole time
I'm thinking we were building this life
and we got this thing these these
beautiful things finna unfold and occur
in our lives when this whole time I was
the only person in this relationship
like I really felt like I had everything
that I wanted
without the value of a dollar and I
lived in a tent but it was taken from me
because he decided to want to mess
around with other women he's our only
found out because of the fact that he
paid my mom don't can I say nothing to
me about this woman
and it was really painful because I
really gave my all to this person and he
just really took my heart after me
telling him if you feel like you're
gonna hurt me please just walk away and
he didn't have the guts to just walk
away
[Music]
and the other gentleman that you were
involved with yes what happened with him
he's actually still in prison right now
and I feel so bad because if he was free
there's nothing in this world that I
couldn't have gotten from him and I felt
like I turned my back on him in the time
that he needed me the most for a piece
of happiness that I wouldn't I would
never receive so you're how far along is
your pregnancy I haven't even been to
the doctor yet so fairly new but I can't
be no more than two months and what's he
in prison for possession how old you 26
26 and we're you working Figueroa you
did that for how long oh I didn't when I
was 18 for about a year then I stopped
for six years after I had my kids but
then life hit me where my nine-to-five
wasn't supportive enough of three kids
in in the world we live in economy is
very expensive so it wasn't enough so it
led me back to the streets and I've been
in the streets since then how much would
you make a night mmm honestly on a good
day I would probably bring like four in
a day and maybe four at night if I did a
double shift or if I just wanted to just
get some stuff out the way before three
was maybe the lowest I would ever bring
you ever get any
that experiences with the guys who
picked up Barry mini one in particular I
had a guy who was pushing his car in the
middle of the streets right at me I'm
just a genuine person like I'd like to
see the good and everybody just because
I like to think that everybody has some
type of good in them so he's pushing
this car in the middle of the streets
he's like hey can you help me you know I
need to just push it so I can get a
jump-start so I'm like okay sir like
let's push your car off the middle of
the street so you won't get a hit it
would push the car to the side he's like
okay well you know I wanna date you
so I get in the car with my friend we
get it started we'd pull around the
corner and the guys like okay one rule
about the game that we never do we don't
provide any services without receiving a
dollar for some reason he would not give
me the dollars and I kept telling him
okay sir well I'm not doing anything
unless you give me two dollars so he
pulls a bottle from underneath the seat
and like he's gonna crack me in the head
with the bottle like you're gonna do
this or I'm finna hit you so I had a
pepper spray on the side of my head and
I took the pepper spray out this is my
first time ever have any experience with
pepper spray so it's kind of food so I
sprayed the pepper spray
not knowing we're in a car that sealed
off I've never been around pepper spray
before so I'm thinking okay I spray them
in the face he's got to get off of me I
spray the pepper spray we both start
coughing I said what the [ __ ] I didn't
get it on me I mean my eyes was wider
and my nose was running he takes off
running down the street crying he left
his car hurt he loves his car me I take
off running the other way my eyes is
just running my nose is running I'm
looking for anybody for help then I run
into another guy he wants to date but
then when we date I get the pepper spray
on the condom so now I'm burning down
here I was like okay listen I'm done I
need to go in huh meows it's over it's a
rat that was one of the crazy
experiences I've experienced on thermal
you ever get raped beaten up stuff like
that no I've almost gotten robbed before
yeah no actually I take that back when I
first started in 2012 there was this guy
out here right he would run around and
pretend like he was a police officer and
I do believe I seen on the news he got
arrested but he would go around and
pretend like he was a police officer
making girls do things oh I know you got
warrants and so he would make him create
X he did it to me before
oh come with me I never done ain't know
a day in my life but that day that man
made me do it because I was so in fear
that I was gonna go to jail he's like
I'm gonna give you a pass if we go
around the corner we do this I cried the
whole time and eventually he let me go I
seen him like driving down the street a
couple of weeks later and he told me to
give him the car he said anytime come
and get you just get in the car and you
and you won't go to jail I'll let them
know not to bother you eventually a
woman found out that it was a fake and
she told and that man was arrested I
seen it on the news after I had left
that lifestyle and it made me feel so
good because it's like it's already a
burden on us as women that we have to do
this and then the fact that people judge
and look at us a certain type of way
because of the hustle that we have is
kind of hard it's kind of really messed
up because you don't know why we why we
ended up here or what we're doing with
the purposes for it's not because we
like it or because we love it maybe it's
the only source of income that we know
of but a lot of people take that as an
advantage oh they're just hoes like they
have no respect or we don't need to show
them any respect we don't need to show
them any type of my respectful
conversation that's not cool because at
the end of the day we still we're still
human beings whether we decide to hustle
with the rock sack or with
the gifts and the abilities that God
blessed us with we have to survive just
like everybody else was giving up that
lifestyle what brought you down to skid
row yes when I left the lifestyle I
ended up one skid row so you ready so
you went we went from south-central to
skid row yes which is a big step down
yes this I tell people all the time I'm
bhujette oh these tents I never knew of
right when I first got down here yeah
there's no there's our textiles on South
Central the first day I got down here I
seen my mom in a tent I see a man I see
everything else I said what why are you
so comfortable in the tea and it took
for me to have to go through it to
understand I think people that watch my
channel don't understand the difference
between South Central and Skid Row they
think they're similar the same thing the
girls on Figueroa dress beautifully they
have great nails they have braces to fix
their teeth if nice cars yes I don't
want to give too much information but
some of the girls are driving Mercedes
Benzes and all kinds of and then Skid
Row is where people don't have anything
no they don't have bank accounts they
don't have money in their pockets they
don't have shoes they don't have
anything very different yes very much so
different there's no similarities yeah
there's no similarities the only thing
that you may see that simular you may
can run into somebody bad there's drugs
and prostitution booked places that you
can get a sack from but there's very
difference because these women down here
and these people down here don't have it
much to give versus the people like the
women on fake will get more than the
women downtown by by multitudes alone
job would cost you $20 here is maybe a
hundred and fifty dollars days yeah is
huge difference and it's sad because
it's like these are humans too when you
were a kid did you have dreams of doing
it doing something with your life I
didn't know yes I've always had a dream
of owning my own hair salon but having
like a little twist to it I wanted to
call it a piece of quiet that a parent
can't find because we have a lot of
single parents out here that can't like
really do things for themselves because
they're they always have their children
or they don't have time for a sitter or
anything so I wanted to create this
business to where people can come and
still unwind and have that quiet time
that they need as adults while their
children are downstairs being careful so
a peace of mind that a parent can't find
you feel like all these years on the
street has changed you somehow yes it's
made me a lot stronger and a lot wiser
without the streets I probably wouldn't
be here I've met a lot of mothers in the
streets and what I mean by that is a
woman that I've never even known before
I met down before I came down here will
come to me and ask me if I ate ask me if
I need anything it's a lot of people
like that you will meet on the streets
versus someone that sitting at your
table expecting a plate you're falling
downtown what are you doing for money
now right now I'm actually just taking
it day by day if it comes to comes if it
doesn't it doesn't
are you back to working the streets
dating guys no because I'm pregnant
self-respect I couldn't do that
well I serve every now and again yes I
will you say serve meaning what
I was so cracked oh I see if we should
come to shove but I receive everything
that I need without the value of a
dollar every day every day you get
depressed sometimes yes I did but what
aspect of all this life gets you down to
most the fact that all three of my
children are not with me anymore like
those are my shadows I couldn't even go
to the bathroom without them so they
look back and not here mom at least a
million times in one sentence it really
tears me up because it's like they are
my everything when I can't find a piece
of happiness I can always look at them
and find it and know that they won't
judge me I just wish that at one point
in time I can actually have us all back
in the same house but if I can say
something to them I would let them know
that I'm trying hard to get back to him
every day I try it's a battle and it's
hard because I miss them so much
I do like kids mm-hm
they can't get a bit irritating at times
but that's just a job then but the
moment that a parent doesn't get to
enjoy that moment anymore or to hear
your kids fighting or to see them riding
bikes through stuff like that it really
hurts when you are a real parent and it
hurts a lot like I don't get to roll
over and see my kids I put them in their
own beds and wake up at 12 o'clock in
the morning and see somebody laying on
my neck or somebody by my foot like it's
really hard you
and you lost them for what reason I
couldn't take care of them anymore I had
no place for us to live and me as a
parent I couldn't take my kids through
that me I'm not stable myself I didn't
want my kids to go through this living
in tents running the streets doing all
that stuff a lot of people would say I
gave up but I didn't I just seemed
better for my kids and it wasn't with me
at this moment so I let them live with
their dad I still have access to phone
calls visits they just physically don't
live in the home with me anymore and
every day I wake up I pray and I fight
hard whatever it is I need to do to get
back to them I'm trying to do anything
no child deserves to grow up without
their parents I grew it with our minds
and it gives you questions that no child
should ever question does my mom love me
was I not good enough I don't ever want
my kids to experience that never because
I did I was a cacao waking up in the
middle of the night not seeing my mom I
want to break the cycle I want to be the
mom that came back
okay thank you so much for sharing your
story no problem I hope you kids back I
hope so too thank you thank you
you